hello and welcome to GameSpot daily
where we cover six news stories in 30
minutes or less or something bad could
happen who knows I'm Callie they're
gonna take away our video games
yeah and I'm joined of course by Michael
hi hello everyone hi it's Thursday
Thirsty Thursday I said it was thirsty
Thursday last week but I was actually
wrong
today's Thursday Thursday is it every
Thursday Thursday Thursday well depends
on how you look at if you want it to be
though all the world's your oyster I
don't know where I'm going with that
sirs the thirst is not quenched around
the world so it's always thirsty
Thursdays somewhere you Bevans Monday
anyway we have a pretty interesting
assortment of stories today I'm pretty
excited we got obviously 49 50 P fifties
back we got pub G news we got Master
Chief collection we got anime as we
always do sort of sort of well yeah
anime an anime mixed with Yakuza which
is the best of both worlds get excited
I'm excited to talk about that but we
got to get through the important stuff
first which of course means fortnight
fortnight 5050 is back and the light
machinegun has been added among other
things so we got a ton of patch notes on
games but I actually want to shout out
Oskar dais for this fantastic story
because he has new table of contents
look how clean that is yeah it's clean
so if you are a big Fortnight fan and
you want to see like the bullet points
everything they added in the three point
five point to update we have it on
GameSpot well what will run you through
the most important stuff so 5350 has
been brought back for a limited time and
I'll pull up the you know initial 50v 50
trailer but época says this one is has
said this one is a new and improved so
yeah excited cool yeah there's also a
bunch of other things that come with
this patch do we want to run through
these these patch notes I mean let's run
through 50 50 while we're watching 50 50
okay well that's these right here yeah
okay okay so the basic there's there's a
number there's a laundry list of things
so the basic thing is each team jumps
out of their own
bus and it has ten minutes and you have
ten minutes to loot before the fighting
starts and the storm closes in you have
five minutes to fight and then five
minutes while another storm closes in so
that's the first one okay that was the
longest bullet point all right supply
drops come in batches of three and three
to six fallen and they fall every two
minutes and only land in the final storm
of the circle so you can be strapping up
at the end of it and at the end of these
matches man hell yeah
they added a dotted line to the map
which indicates the battle lines between
the two teams so if you cross that line
it'll make running into enemies more
likely right obviously duh there's an
increase in loot and wooh let me change
its camera real quick there's an
increase in luton Reis resource pond so
you won't be running into any dry towns
I know I have that problem when I'm
playing regular fortnight yeah always
run into towns ain't got [ __ ] in them
but if you play fifty v50 you won't have
that problem right and then profile
stats are not tracked in this mode
because of the large squads that's
specifically what they said large squads
and then squad based challenges can't be
completed that's related to that yeah 50
V 50 is exciting different way to play
fortnight I've seen some crazy ass
buildings in the firt in the first round
of 50 V 50 and four and I saw some crazy
ass buildings constructed when you have
that big of a team if you haven't
experienced that you can jump in to that
time to check out again they also added
the light machine gun it comes in rare
in epic varieties the rare deals 25
damage while the epic deals 26 damage
mm-hmm and they're found anywhere on the
on the floor and treasure chests and
vending machines and it has a 100 round
mag with medium ammo and a 5 second
reload bang bang there you go we also
have saved the world mode changes yeah
for anybody who's interested in that new
mission called into the storm encore you
complete that to unlock a new cyberpunk
hero which sounds cool a new weapon
which is the mercury light machine gun
it's an energy assault weapon and it's
available in the event store at 5 p.m.
Pacific starting April 19th mm-hmm cool
and there's also other changes obviously
because this patch is quite expansive so
and changes that have been implemented
for peeking which so if you if you've
had this problem where you have a ramp
like my hand visualizations here you're
on a ramp and you're like you're like
peeking you're like trying to take
potshots at someone across there you
would often your shots would collide
with your structure so they have fixed
that I haven't been able to test that
out myself but yeah so you won't be a
shooting your own your own damn
structures when you're trying to take
potshots right which is nice good
there's also double xp in Battle Royale
in all versions of the game from now
through Sunday which is April 22nd and
we have like I said the full patch notes
on gamespot if you want to get into the
nitty-gritty of that but that is what we
hear at games bought daily called
fortnight daily yes for tonight so Oscar
Deus I was gonna say the title we give
to people who are experts in things
we're not going to unveil the secret
title but if you want if your fortnight
man óskar Deus I'm handing off that
title to him so you can follow him you
just want to get rid of being the battle
right I I am I am getting I am handing
off that title to my child
Oscar Deus he's not my child he and I
have the same birthday but he's a couple
years younger than me fun fact
oh yeah that's cute uh in other Battle
Royale news we got hub G updates and I
think I'm having some static on my hair
with this microphone so it's been like
lifting my hair up anyway [ __ ] well duh
Oh pop geez savage map is getting
underground caves and the game is
finally finally adding map selection so
that's a twofer for pub yeah I am really
stoked by the second one but let's talk
about the underground caves because huh
so pub G really air pub G Corp released
a post on Steam which teases some of the
stuff that's coming to codename savage
again I well I don't know if I've said
that on this show life but I have said
before to Michael and I really hope they
change the name of that map because I'm
not a fan of the name Savage it'll have
new vehicles weapons and areas yeah and
there's speaking of one of the new areas
for
codename savage now this one's kind of a
kind of mind boggling if you ask me
there's a real big-ass hole in the
ground
BAM yes a giant hole in the ground yeah
we we will show you what that looks like
or what the concept looks like in
shortly but to talk a little bit about
what the idea is there's a concept
sketch that sorts out and shows kind of
this this hole in the ground that you
can skydive into so it must be pretty
deep if you're gonna whip out like a
parachute or some [ __ ]
and it's leads into that underground
cave that they want to implement which
is essentially like a network of caverns
and the beneath the map so that's
another whole nother type of type of
area within this already condensed map
and some development time is gonna be
needed for this obviously because they
can't just like slap on some new [ __ ]
onto a map and like call it a day yeah
I'm curious that the circle works with
an underground kiss like like what if
you get stuck in that's the own damned
fault then but also like what if the
circle closes and like half of the
people are above ground and half the
people are below all just chillin up
there like oh there's one v1 right now
but he's like down there and I'm like
what if like you're just stuck on the
top and you're like I can't I can't find
this guy and it turns out he's in the
cave well puppey corpus said they're
excited to be rolling this out in the
next couple of testing phases so
hopefully that gives them time to figure
out a situation like that I'm sure
they're thinking about that they gotta
be right I would hope so
umm pochi Corp also said it would talk
about new weapons and vehicles which
include something called a tuk-tuk
and they said soon that's coming soon oh
and I thought this is interesting
because I thought I got like kind of
like a Vietnam or like Southeast Asian
vibe from this map Thailand is
considered Southeast Asia right right I
know but so I felt really proud that I
was on the money with that because the
inspiration for this new map did come
from real cave systems in Thai okay yeah
such as the Franek khan cave which is
home to a temple and if you go on
bangkok comm you get some cool images of
that temple yeah I like that we have
this detail I'm really happy we got the
front front pages check out this new pub
GMaps on Bangkok no that's not true that
no they spitting out some misinformation
it really helped with tourism if it's a
video game
oh no yeah especially a game like pubs
you
yeah look let's show that that giant
hole in the ground concept art you ever
been excited for a big-ass hole in the
ground we'll check this out I was
looking at you talk about the
handwritten notes on this I could
imagine like Brendan Green in there and
be like let me sketch this out for y'all
real quick uh skydive okay so here's the
thing I can't really assume that I'm
sorry but um yeah
giant giant [ __ ] Hall yeah big that's
big yeah then the bottom image is kind
of like oh this is what the underground
network will look like it doesn't look
that extensive I guess there's a pool in
the middle and some trees or stalagmites
cool anyway so there's that there you
have it
anyway so that's that and then finally I
do want to talk about the map selection
because I'm very excited about this
because I hate the desert map some
haters out here y'all so you can vote or
unveil it and the system will choose
between nominations in case of a tie
call of duty's been doing that for a
really oh yeah I just say that because
like I I do like choosing my map and I
get very frustrated when it's like oh
we're going to bog I'm like I don't want
I got a bhag bhag sucks
um anyway that's coming to the test
server first and then to the full game
again soon pub G Corp has just been
saying all of us is soon which I think
is better for them good like creating
multiplayer maps like it doesn't just
just take time but it also takes testing
phases and then you may be confronted
with problems you had not anticipated
which will put an indefinite amount of
development time time on top of what you
already expected so be patient with them
if you're if you're like frothing at the
mouth like give me that third map yo
like calm yo ass but I mean this is
gonna be is exciting you know when when
they even though you hate the second map
the fact that they rolled out the second
map was was a nice treat it was I liked
it at first I like to change a pace I to
be fair to the to miramar I haven't
tried it since they rolled out some
updates and changed like the
northeastern section of that map I was
playing it yesterday last night actually
with my homies so I mean those areas are
more popular than they are
better but overall like the game the map
it's pretty much the same okay I really
need to fix my PC so I can actually play
again and help you
one day I'll break you and you'll help
me with my PC parts all right now we're
gonna an anime are you guys ready I will
I will fix your PC when we get Fist of
the North Star in North America all
right so maybe we will maybe we don't
know but we got a little hint of it a
new Sega survey asks about your interest
in the Fist of the North Star game which
comes from the yucca six developer
developer Ryu GA Gotoku studio this
comes from Sega nerds who second nerds
out there so there's a Fist of the North
Star game that was released on the ps4
in Japan on March 8th and it's called
Hokuto gotoku Hokuto is the North Star
portion of the animes name and obviously
gotoku is like the end of the original
in Japan the Yaak is a game title so
it's kind of like a like a match up of
that because the facility our game in
Japan is basically oh I think it's
reductive to say it's Yakuza yog is a
reskin but it's [ __ ] it's cool
in case you well to set this up a little
bit in case you don't know what Fist of
the North Star is it's a manga and it's
also there was an anime adaptation and
it's set in a post-apocalyptic world
kind of like Mad Max and the main
character is a Kenshiro and he is the
successor to an ancient martial art
style called Hokuto Shinken mmm-hmm and
is the title and that's that would be
the fist of the north yeah and he has
dedicated his life to beating the living
crap out of bandits dictators and anyone
else who threatens the lives of the
innocent and Fist of the North Star is a
pretty classic anime do you know when it
came out like a tease yeah it's like a
it's like an early 80s I think cuz it
was before Dragonball um so yes so just
so you know what Fist of the North Star
is the survey that Sega put out says
quote while no localization has been
announced at this time how interested
are you
the Fist of the North Star game created
by the developers of Yakuza pretty
pretty like hey guys would if we if we
brought this to America would you buy it
yes how kind of question is that
hell yeah man so if you want to know
look so this came out in Japan in March
8 and it's basically it has all the it
has the same foundation as Yakuza even
like some of the sound effects are the
same as yahooza like some of the skill
trees are the same that look look the
same as Yakuza and also the original
voice actor for Kazuma Kiryu is voicing
Kenshiro in the game so it's like it's
as if kiri you just like transformed
into and like got a quark who can summon
fireballs and yeah kill people by
sticking his fingers in their head for
10 seconds it looks and even sounds like
a reskin of Jakob but obviously Fist of
the North Star has unique things yeah
the same skill tree as Jakob yeah and I
did I just looked it up Fist of the
North Star is early 80s to confirm yes
83 was when it first started being
serialized and shown and jump so there
there have been Fist of the North Star
games that came out in the u.s. some as
far back as the 80s which is you can't
say the same thing about Dragon Ball
Dragon Ball is probably not probably is
way more popular way more well-known but
the first Dragon Ball game that came out
in the West was in the 80s but it was
totally re skinned and it doesn't have
anything to do with Dragon Balls called
dragon power
did a whole feature on that if you want
to check that out on the history of the
Dragon Ball videogames but the fact that
Fist of the North Star Games came to
America in the 80s is like shocking to
me so the most recent ones work enraged
games from Tecmo Koei that came in 2010
to ps3 and 360 and then Ken's rage 2 was
in 2013 on ps3 360 and Wii U even what's
going on with you I'm watching on the
side of my eye I'm watching the trailer
and it's so goddamn cute it's so
adorable
it's exactly like Yakuza but what's
super powers and that's actually it's a
different kind of thing for a Fist of
the North Star game because the Ken's
rage games are actually more like Co a
tecmo soul games like the dynasty
Warriors series
so this is like totally different and it
looks it actually looks super Mad Max
that's very mad I see I know I haven't
seen Fist of the North Star reddit or
anything so this is like my first
exposure
oh yes trailer this is just anime
matsuri of a Yakuza game with all the
absurdity and you know describing
Kenshiro as a character is almost easy
basically in parallel with cosmic you
who is this like dead ass serious guys
gonna whoop your ass if you mess with
innocent people and he has a heart of
gold but he don't take no [ __ ] from
nobody and man and he's voiced by by the
original voice actor his name is oh
sorry I scrolled down his name is
t'keyah Kuroda yeah so he is the
original voice act or he has been the
voice actor for eternity for a cosmic
area and he's going to be doing for you
guys it does Kenshiro voice but yeah the
story of the day is egg is asking us if
we want this in the in the West and the
answer is yes please please so I also
want to shout out the person in the
YouTube chat who just said not he and
the other person who said oh my emotion
hey hey we hear y'all was here I see a
cyborg man I see you in the chat oh man
I want Fist of the North Star please
please Sega so yes if you can get ahold
of that survey somehow make sure you
answer yes because that is a correct
answer yes thank you thank you for your
time back to back to back to reality
I took western video games we got a cool
thing from PC gamer on the halo Master
Chief collection which could eventually
add decade old fan made maps which is
crazy to me so in a recent Halo Waypoint
post 343 industries community manager
manager Brian Gerrard detailed how
development on the Master Chief
collection is progressing and one of the
more interesting things is that there's
work being done on bringing the fan made
halo custom Edition Maps to the game did
you ever play halo custom edition mmm no
I'm sorry I fell off halo after hay
before but oh well actually I play back
get me started on
Tana cuz I'll get our halo lor is the
halo lor is very complicated
I actually correct myself I did play
Master Chief collection I yeah I was a
little broken to begin with um a little
broken so halo custom edition was an
unofficial add-on for the PC version of
halo combat Evolved so the original halo
that came out in 2004 and it's still
live and it's basically just a modding
platform for beatle so gerrard
the like i said the community manager
over at 343 you want to read this
question yes I'll read the quote um but
but it a bit this is this is this is
longer lead proof proof of concept work
that isn't part of the near-term scope
but engineer Shawn Cooper shared some
exciting progress successfully loading a
halo custom edition map into mcc which
is Master Chief collection there's a lot
of rough edges and plenty of work to do
work to still do on this front and to be
honest this feature won't work this this
feature work isn't currently even tied
to the official milestone but it's a
it's a really tantalizing and exciting
prospect to think about further down the
road wow I need to learn how to read
Girard also detailed what the team is
prioritizing for the first Master Chief
for the first of the Master Chief
collection updates which includes Xbox
one excellence Mundson
you know matchmaking improvements the
things that it should have had from the
beginning besides the Xbox 1x
improvements cuz obviously that didn't
exist when it released but yeah more
more halo for the people out there who
want to play more halo and putting
custom stuff in their hands I think they
know the community doesn't dope [ __ ] if
you ever seen like a lot of the forged
stuff I it's very creative my brother
and I used to play this one Forge map
that's I was called Omega slip and slide
and it was just like a bunch of vehicles
at the top and you just had to keep
going down it was like this infinite
loop and you would gain momentum but we
were all a on zombies mode so it was it
was just hectic it was like the most
hectic thing I've ever done
hello because you just kept like he
would go super fast and like you would
run over
sounds like surf maps and counter-strike
yeah I'm all about them them surf maps
and CS yeah so there you go cool we have
two more stories left but these are
quick ones
we got quick ones and we start a little
bit late but we gotta make room for more
live streams here at GameSpot so we'll
get through these quickly this one I
think is the one that that like I'm just
I feel very like Mormon talking about
hell-blade sells 50,000 copies on Xbox
one it just came out for Xbox one two
weeks ago and it donates 20 and the and
the team donated $25,000 to a mental
health charity that's Ninja Theory
that's Ninja Theory and they've done
this before for mental health awareness
they did a like a it was like all
proceeds or like part of the proceeds
for a certain period of time went to
mental health charities it's something
that the team seems to really believe in
so oh we have we have a launched on Xbox
one on April 11th
so I updated the review of two weeks ago
but it launched pretty recently it sold
50,000 copies in the first week like we
said and the charity that they donated
to was Mental Health America it was
really cool and they had a stretch goal
of though they had yeah had a stretch
goal of 100,000 copies by yesterday
April 18th and if met of what what hold
on there yeah so they add a stretch goal
for April 18th if Matt donations were
increased by 50,000 a button engine to
fit yeah to 50,000 not not to 50,000 to
50,000 if that doesn't make any sense to
y'all listening that never mind but has
not announced new numbers since crossing
the 50k 50k sales mark but still $25,000
there's nothing to sneeze at obviously
and mental health is something that it's
really important and I think is often
misunderstood and that's something that
send you a sacrifice really tried to do
like that game is very good at
communicating really communicates just a
really sympathetic and and often
relatable a story of mental health
struggle and so I just think it's cool
the developer is backing that the hell
up
and so if you haven't played hell blade
support Ninja Theory seriously play hell
blade it's so good
they made it in our top 10 games of 2017
yeah if you're into the Norse mythology
of God of War
oh you get a full rundown in Hell blade
of all of those Norse gods and it's
really it's really cool yeah I mean with
an accent tells you about Amir and Odin
and all that [ __ ] yeah that's dope
he'll blade first came out on ps4 and PC
in August 2017 which is why it was on
our games list for 2016 and then it's
also it has enhancements on Xbox one X
yes so I'll you want X owners out there
don't want to get into help light you do
get a little some some at 4k and and
60fps or up to 4k so it might do it it
does might do a dynamic resolution sure
but that is a side note to the bigger
story which is the fact that ninja
theory is putting some money for for
mental Hera mental health organization
Ninja Theory all right last story this
is one's really fast
literally check out this $1,000 neo
stash right piece that's it there's a
there's a sick geo statue that costs
$1000 is that garel it looks actually
I'm just like Daryl it looks like we had
this Daryl like statue with a nooner 8th
yeah in the in the office it's a it's
all life this looks a lot like that
actually it's like a similar composition
anyway yeah it's a life-size one no the
Carroll one oh it's not he's its large
it's always bigger yeah they're all this
large so this do statue comes from Prime
one studio and it's a statue of William
Adams who is the protagonist of neo
which came out last year of course it
comes with his guardian spirit
Saoirse I've always I've read that as
Sauer oice for like my whole life it's
actually pronounce Saoirse that's
alcohol it's 24 inches tall and only 750
are being made so if you want to drop
$1,000 on a statue of this nice man who
looks like Darrell you better get on
that
there's shipping next year between June
and August 2019
there's always off there's
said your dollar version available if
you uh you don't break the bank it's
less detail
it doesn't include Saoirse and it stands
at 17 inches tall not 24 inches
sacrificing those inches that's it
story of my life all right we got to get
out of here thank you Matt Tony Wilson
Chris Pereira who's sick but thank you
for existing Eric Tay Emily Conti am I
forgetting anyone Oh use that Eric tang
I just want to give a double shout out
to Eric tape man that that fool is
running around the office making make a
[ __ ] pot man he's done this for years so
well troubleshooter in human form
walking troubleshooting he's one of my
favorites he's great and thank you for
watching
oh yeah you all of you are one of my one
of my favorites that's why all of you
are my favorites grammars is it's
constructs
I'm not damn it anyway we will be back
tomorrow Friday have a fun Thirsty
Thursday and stay safe bye bye